leute es ist mittlerweile eine der
längsten tradition die wir hier auf
doktor watson haben wissenschaft und
auch das vierte jahr in folge habe ich
wieder youtube kolleginnen und kollegen
gefragt was war ihrer meinung nach das
wichtigste was dieses jahr in der
wissenschaft passiert wer den rückblick
letztes jahr gesehen hat der weiß dass
es ganz schön schwierig war aus diesem
jahr positiv heraus zu gehen und viele
probleme aus 2020 haben wir leider auch
mit in 2021 geschleppt ich finde aber im
gegensatz zu letztem jahr haben sich
schon mal viele dinge verbessert zum
beispiel haben wir jetzt an den
wichtigen und sicheren baustein um aus
der pandemie herauszukommen bis
redaktionsschluss konnten wir in
deutschland 70 prozent der bevölkerung
impfen und ich finde es ganz schön krass
wenn man sich das mal vor augen hält
weltweit hat es ein jahr gedauert bis
100 millionen menschen sich mit dem
corona virus infiziert haben dank der
wissenschaft konnten wir anfang 2021
innerhalb von nur sechs wochen 100
millionen impfdosen verabreichen dieses
jahr haben wir den virus wirklich den
kampf angesagt trotzdem liefen natürlich
bei weitem nicht alles reibungslos und
70 prozent sind leider nicht genug ich
bin ja schon zwei bald hoffentlich drei
mal geimpft und kann euch nur dasselbe
empfehlen denn die wissenschaft ist sich
einig die zugelassenen impfstoffe sind
sicher und retten leben und wenn ihr
oder leute die erkennt zögern oder
sorgen haben dann schaut euch gerne
unser video zum thema impfstoffe an und
ob die zu schnell produziert wurden oder
lest euch diesen artikel hier vom
spiegel durch da werden viele
berechtigte sorgen und ängste
angesprochen am liebsten spreche ich
natürlich über neue entdeckungen über
durchbrüche oder allgemein positive
dinge aber auch dieses jahr gab es
leider nicht so schöne dinge die die
wissenschaft beschäftigt hat vor allem
in nrw und rheinland-pfalz haben
flutkatastrophen nicht nur ganze dörfer
zerstört sondern auch menschenleben
gekostet wissenschaftlerinnen und
wissenschaftler ziehen einen direkten
bezug zur klimakrise ich werde dazu wie
immer unten in der video beschreibung
das sind wichtige erkenntnisse die klar
machen dass uns nicht mehr viel zeit
bleibt umweltkatastrophen werden in den
nächsten jahren und jahrzehnten immer
häufiger und immer heftiger und sonst so
nun neben wichtigen und alarmierenden
erkenntnissen gab es dieses jahr auch
ganz schön skurril
dinge in maskat den tesla bord
angekündigt
die ganze welt hat gespürt was passiert
wenn ein schiff in einem kanal stecken
bleibt und zwei milliardäre haben sich
einen ganz schönen seltsamen wettlauf
ins all geliefert
paid for orders und wo wir schon mal bei
der raumfahrt sind natürlich dürfen wir
provence nicht vergessen seit februar
diesen jahres erkundet der rover jetzt
schon den mars sie werden so schnell
erwachsen aber spaß beiseite neben prinz
ist natürlich auch ingenuity auf dem
mars gelandet dieses jahr haben wir das
erste mal in der geschichte der
menschheit ein objekt auf einem anderen
planeten fliegen lassen und seitdem tun
wir das einfach regelmäßig bevor ich
hier aber alles vorweg nehme gebe ich
jetzt mal besser an meine lieben youtube
kolleginnen und kollegen ab was war 2021
das wichtigste was in der wissenschaft
passiert ist hier sind ihre antworten
mein wissenschafts highlight 2021 war
diese studie und zwar der einsatz von
mdma zur behandlung von
posttraumatischen belastungsstörungen
die posttraumatische belastungsstörung
ist eine schwere psychische erkrankung
und entsteht als folge schwerer
traumatischer erfahrungen in vielen
fällen schaffen dass die betroffenen
nicht die therapie ohne den einsatz von
einem medikament zu ende zu bringen das
problem ist aber dass die aktuell
gängigen präparate weil 40 bis 60
prozent der patienten nicht anschlagen
und genau hier kamen jetzt mdma zum
einsatz in demag kennt ihr vielleicht
als partydroge dazu habe ich ja auch
schon ein selbstexperiment gemacht die
forscher versprechen sich dass beim
einsatz von mdma in verbindung mit einer
therapie die patienten diese
traumatischen erfahrungen erneut erleben
und verarbeiten können und das ganz ohne
dass die sich schlecht fühlen zb wegen
scham oder gut durch die studie konnte
festgestellt werden dass mdma im
vergleich zum placebo stark zur
minderung der symptome der
posttraumatischen belastungsstörungen
beigetragen hat also ich find das mega
faszinierend und ich bin sehr gespannt
was es noch so für wissenschaftliche
ergebnisse zu anderen vermeintlichen
drogen geben wird mein name ist marlene
von kanal doktor wissen und mein
wissenschafts highlight des jahres 2021
ist eine impfung gegen krebs die bei
untergründige sahin und smtp haben nicht
nur den berühmten corona dem ehrenabend
stoff entwickelt der uns hoffentlich
bald aus dieser pandemie hilft sondern
ursprünglich ihre forschung an m rna
begonnen um eine waffe zur bekämpfung
von tumoren zu entwickeln und diese
forschung nicht sogar ziemlich
erfolgreich bis uns corona in den weg
kam aber jetzt wird weiter geforscht wie
funktioniert das ganze die impfung gegen
krebs ist keine vorbeugende impfung wie
etwa die korona impfung die uns vor
einer möglichen infektion schützen soll
sondern sie soll unser immunsystem so
stimulieren dass ein bereits vorhandener
tumore effektiv bekämpft werden kann die
mmr impfung enthält baupläne für
wichtige bestandteile eines tumors die
sich auf unseren normalen körperzellen
nicht finden durch die impfungen wird
unser körper dazu gebracht diese
bestandteile jetzt selber herzustellen
und unserem immunsystem zu präsentieren
dass dann die tumorzellen leichter
erkennen und attackieren kann noch steht
die forschung am anfang und die methode
funktioniert leider auch nicht bei allen
krebsarten aber in diesem jahr gab es
bereits erste phase 2 studien mit
testung am menschen das bedeutet es gibt
hoffnung dass impfstoffe gegen krebs bei
zugelassen werden könnten hey ich bin
informatiker und videoproduzent auf
youtube für mich war das
wissenschaftliche highlight 2021
definitiv googles durchbruch in der
forschung zu künstlicher intelligenz
erstmals gelang es forschern das floor
planning das ist ein sehr aufwendiges
problem bzw ein arbeitsschritt beim
computer chip design vollständig mit
künstlicher intelligenz zu
automatisieren ziel beim flop planning
ist ein plan zu entwickeln das alle
bauteile auf dem chip platz finden und
richtig miteinander verkabelt werden
können normalerweise brauchen studierte
erfahrene experten und dafür mehrere
monate dass die brain force mit learning
module von google hingegen konnte
bessere chips nach wenigen stunden
liefern wir laufen gerade auf eine welt
zu in der selbst menschen mit
expertenwissen in tragenden beruflichen
rollenmaschinen unterlegen sein werden
wie die menschheit mit diesen chancen
und risiken umgehen wird wird in den
nächsten jahren und jahrzehnten
unglaublich spannend wäre es nicht ein
traum das menschengemachte co2 wieder
aus der atmosphäre direkt unter die erde
zu bringen ich bin tomtom instagram und
neulich auch youtube kanal doktor
wissenschaft und mein diesjähriges
highlight ist der betriebsstart der
bisher größten co2 speicherung anlage
der welt in island die anlagetechnik
beruht darauf dass co2 aus der
atmosphäre in wasser zu lösen und dann
1000 meter tief zu basalt halt im
gestein zu pumpen über mehrere monate
reagiert das co2 im wasser mit dem
basalt zu karbonaten das klimaschädliche
co2 wird sozusagen versteinert und durch
diese umwandlung potenzial für immer aus
der atmosphäre verwandt was seine coole
technik vor allem wenn man bedenkt dass
man nicht groß in die ökosysteme
eingreift sondern einfach gesteine
herstellt dse schon seit millionen
jahren auf der erde gibt in zukunft
könnte man die abgase der industrie auch
direkt diesen prozess zu führen noch ist
die technik sehr energieaufwendig und
teuer sie ist nur eine region mit basalt
haltiger und wasserreiche erde und einem
überschuss erneuerbare energien sinnvoll
aber es macht mich wirklich
zuversichtlich dass die wissenschaft und
auch teilweise coole startups richtig
gas geben lösung für die klimakrise zu
finden haye noch einen trick dazu
entspricht ich bin vom kanal gebaut von
loks und dem auf facebook torrijos
meiner meinung nach das größte ereignis
sowohl für den journalismus die
forschung als auch die politik im
bereich cyber security war dieses jahr
wohl der staatstrojaner pegasus denen
das israelische unternehmen msm group an
eine vielzahl von staaten verkaufte der
trojaner hat sich über eine
schwachstelle in whats app installiert
ohne dass die opfer irgendwas davon
bemerkten und dort update funktionen
deaktiviert und spionage betrieben dass
so eine schwachstelle gefunden wird ist
sehr ungewöhnlich denn software wie
whatsapp und ios werden ja engen test
unterzogen und ständig repariert das
schlimmste an dem beispiel ist aber dass
starten siko diesen trojaner gegen
journalisten und aktivisten angewendet
haben auch deutschland hat eine leicht
veränderte version von pegasus immer
noch in gebrauch dadurch dass das aber
an die öffentlichkeit geriet konnten die
software hersteller die lücken
identifizieren und schließen was euch
und eure geräte nun auch gegen
gewöhnliche hacker mehr schützt die
können diese lücke nehme ich jetzt auch
nicht mehr benutzen und gerade durch
diese debatte ist so viel mehr im
bereich cyber security geschehen
bewusstseinsforschung es mehr geworden
und der druck auf die regierung ist
immens all das macht den hackern ihr
leben deutlich schwerer ein riesiges
stadions da bricht ungebremst durch die
wolkendecke plötzlich legte seine flügel
an stehst wutschnaubend flammen aus und
dreht seinen über 100 tonnen schweren
körper schlagartig aus der waagerechten
in die senkrechte ja dass das die
ungebremst auf die nur wenige meter
entfernten strand boden zu aber gegen
jede intuition bremsen die
raketentriebwerke dass das schreiben
rechtzeitig ab und landen den prototypen
auf dem landeplatz das war dieses jahr
und nur ein test für die größte und
stärkste jemals gebaute rakete die soll
in den nächsten wochen starten und
komplett wiederverwendbare werden das
wäre ein game changer der die raumfahrt
einmal so günstig machen könnte dass du
und ich uns flüge in den weltraum
leisten könnten ja selbst was sagt es
ist noch gar nicht klar ob vollständige
wiederverwendbarkeit überhaupt technisch
möglich ist so schwierig ist das aber
allein die idee schon die möglichkeit
lässt weltweiten den gewohnten raumfahrt
fans in eine optimistische zukunft
schauen erde retten oder erde verlassen
lasst uns beides tun nein ich bin roma
von dem kanal entschuldigt und mein
persönliches highlight dieses jahr war
ein experiment welches die
unschärferelation selbst infrage
gestellt hat ein experiment welches
quantenverschränkung auf der makroebene
aufgezeigt hat die wissenschaftler haben
nämlich einen weg gefunden die
heisenbergsche unschärferelation zu
umgehen die unschärferelation besagt
nämlich dass unmöglich ist die position
und den impuls eines teilchens
gleichzeitig bestimmen zu können das
messen eine eigenschaft erzeugt
automatisch eine unschärfe in der
anderen und dennoch haben müsst ihr
wieder geschafft zwei kleine vibrierende
trommeln miteinander zu verschränken der
effekt bei den messbar und beobachtbar
doch auf unserer ebene ist dieser effekt
völlig unbedeutend aber in der
subatomaren welt ist dieser effekt tiefe
der natur der quantenwelt selbst
verankert warum es dieser effekt also so
wichtig für uns nun wir waren hier an
eine grenze zu überschreiten
eine grenze zwischen der klassischen
physik und der quantenphysik was
unglaublich ist bisher war es ja nicht
so einfach zu sagen ob einzelne
starkregen ereignisse oder hitzewellen
zum beispiel am klimawandel liegen denn
der macht ihr erstmal nur
wahrscheinlicher und heftiger aber
gelegentlich gibt die natürlich auch
ohne hier tut sich aber gerade sehr viel
denn dadurch dass unsere klimamodelle
immer präziser werden immer
vollständiger werden immer schneller
berechnet werden ist es inzwischen
möglich zu schauen wie hätte denn so ein
einzelnes konkretes
extremwetterereignisse aus gesehen in
einer welt ohne menschgemachten
klimawandel in der sonst alles gleich
mehr nur weniger co2 in der luft
feuchteren böden kühlere mehrere und so
weiter und der vergleich zum
tatsächlichen gemessenen wetter lässt
uns ja sehen wie sehr der klimawandel
zum beispiel so eine hitzewelle prägt ob
wir die sonst vielleicht trotzdem gehabt
hätten oder nicht oder einfach nur
anders die idee dahinter ist natürlich
nicht neu aber dieser ganze bereich der
sogenannten attribution forschung
entwickelt sich gerade rasend schnell
und wird auch immer wichtiger zum
beispiel um zu ermitteln welche schäden
zum beispiel kohle öl und gaskonzerne
durch ihre emissionen verursachen hey
ich bin taktisch proben kanal taktisch
und einer meiner favoriten dieses jahr
war definitiv alles was rund um das
james webb teleskop passiert ist denn
dieses milliarden euro teure projekt
lädt leider unter großen verzögerungen
am 22 12 2021 sollte es dann in seine
umlaufbahn gebracht werden aber
verzögerungen aber das projekt zu halten
dennoch zu meinen favoriten dieses jahr
ich bin ja von youtube kanal brechen und
dieses jahr ist die ehre dass sich die
nobelpreisträger berlin ist live team zu
gast hatte und konnte ihm die frage
stellen was er für die größte innovation
hält wäre das schönste was nicht
chemiker jetzt für die menschheit
bereitstellen könnte zwei kinder aber
ich stelle mir vor dass co2 den wir aus
der luft filtern das umwandeln des
umgangs zweiten zeh ein theoretiker hat
das ist zusammen mit berechnet auf dem
bierdeckel relativ einfach zu berechnen
ist wir sind ja alles die standard
entertain unterwegs gibt es formulare ja
unseren kleid winzige winzige oder
könnte es eigentlich einfachste fast
einfluss die chemische reaktion ist
eigentlich der wunderschönen so kürzte
photosynthese co2 zu 10 2 ist quasi
dasselbe - was nimmt das was er lange
zeit als vorstadt und überträgt das auf
eine technologie die die welt verbessern
könnte und das klingt für mich
persönlich sehr sehr gut außerdem macht
und das natürlich auch direkt lust auf
das nest ja ich will ihn besuchen und
mir anschauen was alles genau hinter
seiner idee steht vielen lieben dank an
alle youtuber rinnen und youtuber die
mitgemacht haben alle links zu den
jeweiligen kanälen findet ihr unten in
der video beschreibung schaut sie euch
sehr gerne an denn sie machen alle
wirklich gute videos sonst hätten wir
sie hierzu nicht eingeladen natürlich
konnten wir nicht über alles sprechen
was 2021 passiert ist und genau deswegen
lohnt es sich besonders bei diesen
videos hier mal unten in die kommentare
zu schauen ich möchte von euch wissen
was waren eure highlights
oder einfach nur spannende entdeckungen
2021 die nicht jeder auf dem schirm hat
also lasst uns in den kommentaren über
die wissenschaft im jahr 2021 sprechen
ich freue mich schon sehr drauf und
jedes jahr möchte ich mir auch die zeit
nehmen mich zu bedanken vor allem bei
euch als zuschauerinnen und zuschauer
ohne euch könnten wir alle nicht jeden
tag das machen was wir lieben
wissenschaft aufbereiten darüber
diskutieren und die welt jede woche
hoffentlich ein bisschen smarter machen
ihr die ihr die videos guckt die
kommentieren die licon die die videos
teilen und vor allem die page fans die
uns direkt finanziell unterstützen macht
das hier erst möglich und damit komme
ich auch schon zum nächsten punkt das
team wir sind dieses jahr wieder größer
geworden und ich freue mich dass wir
jetzt stefan und pascal als tatkräftige
unterstützung im schnitt und hinter der
kamera mit im boot haben nicht vergessen
darf ich an der stelle aber natürlich
auch die alten hasen im team also alt da
wir sind alle maximal 27 oder 28 oder so
letztes jahr aber auch dieses jahr und
hoffentlich noch viele weitere jahre
arbeiten wie jede woche daran dass wir
euch spannende videos liefern können und
ich kann das nicht allein das ist alles
nur wegen des teams das dahintersteht
danke an euch dass ihr das möglich macht
okay das war
2021 und alles in allem bin ich optimist
durch und freue mich auf ein spannendes
2022 mit noch mehr science noch mehr
meint blau und hoffentlich auch auf wir
sehen uns nächstes jahr etwas später
wieder denn wir gehen jetzt erstmal in
eine kleine winter verschnaufpause
genießt die feiertage so gut es geht
seid vorsichtig lasst euch bitte impfen
und bleibt neugierig patrick